hello and welcome to this exciting video
do you want to design apps and websites
that stand out and get loved by users
everywhere you're in the perfect spot
today I'm revealing five mind-blowing
uxui design tips that will Skyrocket
Your Design skills overnight and guess
what these secrets are straight from our
toprated uiu Playbook that has already
helped thousands of people with more
than 6,000 downloads and a five-star
rating the uiux Playbook has already
become a trusted companion for people
like you
why do people love it because it's
packed with practical tips step-by-step
guides and real world examples that turn
Theory into practice empowering you to
create designs that are not just good
but absolutely incredible you can find
the link in the description and stick
around I've got a massive surprise for
you at the end that you won't want to
miss all right let's start with the
first awesome UI design tip use size
weight color and visual cues to
differentiate information a common
mistake in UI design is presenting all
the information with no clear
distinctions leading to a monotonous
visual experience in such scenarios
users can struggle to differentiate or
prioritize information the design on the
left relies on label and value Fields
while this might seem efficient
presenting all the information on a page
in the same manner results in a lack of
visual hierarchy this makes it difficult
for users to scan the page and identify
important information by leveraging
formatting options like font weight font
size and color as well as visual cues
like icons you can direct the user's
attention to what truly matters and make
the whole design much more visually
exciting okay let's look at another
awesome tip prioritize important
information before even touching the
design list out the features or elements
you have to include in your UI design
and rank them based on their importance
to the user then you can use the color
size position and contrast to
effectively highlight the key
information and guideance users through
the interface intuitively a common
mistake is emphasizing the wrong
elements for example consider two
designs that display three metrics in
the first example the titles of the
metrics like sales earnings and view
have large funds taking the focus away
from the actual values in the second
example the important figures like 591
sales are more prominent giving users
the information they seek more quickly
the second design gets it right by
making the key Val stand out while
making the labels less prominent you
help users find what they're looking for
more easily the third tips is about
using soft shadows in your UI designs
Shadows can either make or break the
aesthetic of your UI design a common
mistake is to use Shadows that are too
harsh or too distinct which can create
an overbearing effect and make your UI
look unprofessional the trick is to opt
for softer Shadows that blend well with
the background and add just the right
amount of depth without overwhelming the
design let's have a look at the
following example the first card has a
strong rough shadow that doesn't look
great and is not very aesthetically
pleasing but the second card uses a
lighter smoother shadow that fits better
with the design and creates a beautiful
clean look while we are on the topic of
Shadows I have another super pro tip for
you match your Shadow color to the
background that is behind it when
applying Shadows it's not just about the
softness or depth the color also matters
a lot matching the color of your Shadow
to your background can make a huge
difference in the aesthetic of your
design let's explore this with an
example featuring a light purple
background in the first case a gray
Shadow is applied to the element in the
second case the shadow has a tint of
purple to match the background the gray
shadow in the first example may look
like a safe bet but it actually clashes
with the light purple background it
breaks the visual Harmony and the result
feels jarring on the other hand the
second example with a tinted purple
Shadow Blends seamlessly with the
background creating a visually appealing
design once you learn this trick you'll
never go back to using pure gray or
black Shadows on colored backgrounds
it's an easy but impactful trick to
improve your UI designs time for the
next tip optimize and test your product
images to increase conversion ever
wondered why some products fly off the
virtual shelves While others gather
digital dust it's not just about having
an incredible product it's how you
present it to the world yes presentation
is is everything so let's dive into a
real life example that illustrates the
power of a few strategic design tweaks
using none other than our very own uiux
Playbook imagine two versions of the uiu
Playbook cover in front of you one is
not so good and the other absolutely
stunning why does one pop and the other
flop it's the uiux design principles in
action matching backgrounds clear
hierarchy striking contrast and more all
creating perfect visual Harmony these
are the same principles you'll Master
with the uiu Playbook but let's say
you've nailed the perfect cover great
start yet there's a catch even the most
eye-catching cover can lose its charm if
not presented well consider this your
ebook is showcased against a plain
background simple Yes effective maybe
but we can do better we've done a few
experiments to increase conversion
imagine presenting the ebook against a
background that not only highlights the
book but also shows its key value
proposition points this tweak alone
bumped our average conversion rate to
22% that's good but not great so we went
back to the drawing board and the result
a presentation that doubled our success
overnight catapulting our conversion
rate to an astonishing 48% right off the
bat what was the game changer showcasing
actual pages from inside the Playbook
this sneak peek not only Built
excitement about what lies within but
also fostered trust and transparency
with potential readers it proved that
letting people see what they're getting
can significantly impact their decision
to engage is our design perfect no
there's always room for improvement and
that's the lesson here always be in
pursuit of Excellence test optimize and
test again your designs can always get
better and so can your conversion rates
feeling inspired that's just a taste
grab the uiu Playbook by using the link
below and learn how to create amazing UI
designs that people love and because
you're awesome I'm giving you a
jaw-dropping 60% off with the code VIP
60 but it's a Time limited offer so make
sure to use it now this Playbook is your
golden ticket to getting that dream
design job freelancing or just making
stuff that's seriously cool thousands of
designers are already leveling up with
it what is stopping you but wait there's
more there's a part two coming with even
more design gold I hope you enjoyed this
video and I will see you in the next one